i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of movies and
television shows so what do you think
maybe would like surprise people to
learn about the actual making of this
film that none of us like each other
i think they'd be surprised that uh
uh uh this is the first time i'm in a
room with anthony it's true 100 that's
true
like we did everything over zoom pretty
much i've known mark for years from
comedy but um
this is our first time meeting face to
face
and and uh we were doing everything over
zoom and you know especially with the uh
and just you would film by yourself
so the the directors are on zoom and
and i'm i'm working in the studio
booth or whatever i think i just had a
stroke but uh yeah
yeah that's a i i don't think people
really
know how many times you go through these
these lines or how long it really takes
to put an animated movie together we've
been working on this since 1997
and uh
it's it takes a lot of time pierre was
literally 14 years old when he started
directing this feature
and and it just takes a long time but
because you can constantly evolve the
characters and put things together and
everything's growing you know a lot of
times we didn't see you know they would
bring us parts of the movie in in black
and white sketches that moved like it
was crazy that the the behind the scenes
of animation is kind of interesting
because outside of the voices there's so
many people figuring out how a snake
moves like when they gave me the part
i'm like how are you gonna get that
thing to walk
and uh and they figure it out it's kind
of amazing
yeah i mean things like the song in the
in the movie wasn't even in the script
when the like really it wasn't no they
did pierre and damon
i came into uh i came into the studio to
record some some more lines
and then they were like yo we have this
idea and we think you should sing in the
movie
one of the great musical performers they
decided like why don't we use him
i got an idea let's have anthony sing
stuff wow i never thought of that i said
sure thing let's
let's do it i recorded you know i
recorded that like recently that the
final cut on that on that uh that song
so yeah that that's the thing every time
i talk to people who are involved in
animation it's always amazing to me that
these projects start so many years ago
and go through so many iterations
like did you when you were first like
signed on agreed to do it when you first
started recording were your characters
like radically different did you go
through any radical changes i it didn't
go through a lot of radical changes i
mean you know once they because these
were pre-existing characters in the
books right so they sort of had a way
but who knew how they were going to talk
so i i think what what really evolves is
they tighten their story is that once
they see how we do the characters they
can sort of you know exploit that or
work to our our strengths and and that's
part of the process of building the
characters up i think changed lines here
and there you give him a song
for for all three of you guys um
uh what are you actually most excited
for like families and audiences to see
in the movie i'm excited just to see
how
parents and kids enjoy it you know
simultaneously because i think it's one
of those movies and i think that's uh
that's sort of where animation's at and
i want to see what the the feedback as
families go together what that is
yeah and it's fun man i mean it's a it's
an action movie there's comedy there's
um there's a beautiful story at the
heart of it you know i think
uh it's you know you see it's called the
bad guys but you know i think every bad
guy has good in them you know and and
and i think we we see all of these
characters going their own journey
individually you see in this in this
film as well as together
in um
discovering the good in in in themselves
you know and uh and um and i just think
it's a it's gonna be a fun movie for
adults and kids you know sweet sweet
yeah
correct
yes
okay you
i've long lost the question at this
point
[Music]
but um
but yes i'm sure i agree with them
you know you just you just agreed to
give your salary in the sequel to these
guys
thank you
you're welcome i deserve that
um uh anthony i actually have an
individual question for you i'm kind of
excited for the new transformers movie
uh what can you actually tease about it
it's about to be crazy that's what i
could tease no it's gonna be fire you
know beast wars and
autobots and
new characters dominique fishback is
amazing stephen cable jr is an
incredible director
um and i'm just i'm just grateful that
they asked me to be a part of it i think
i think it's gonna be something that
people have never seen before are you a
robot i am
it's live action it's live action wow
i'm not a robot i'm the human guy oh
you're not in the machine no okay i
don't know anything about it
i know that people like them
congratulations thanks man
i appreciate it man thank you
it's a big movie
i gotta stop here they're gonna throw me
out listen uh guys um uh thank you so
much for your time i hope the film's a
huge head